[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to GameSpot's
III stage I'm Mike McCarty here as
always with Lucy James hey there we are
here with Jacob Mickelson we are gonna
be talking about hitman to show a game
that was teased a little bit before e3
Warner Brothers released the kind of
like the the racer the racing track and
there's like kind of like speculating
what it was but what's it like to
finally have the game announced and
showing off absolutely absolutely great
to kind of you know spill the beans and
then show people what we've been cooking
up right so it's a it's it's it's yeah
that's a great reactions people are
playing the game in the booth and having
a lot of fun with it so it's really
really great to see agent 47 in the wild
again doing his thing so it's been very
very yeah fantastic today's it's hitman
2 and then people were wondering if it
was like season 2 or whatever so can you
talk about that the decision to not go
episodic with this well the thing is
that I think season 1 prayer the
previous game did I did a lot of kind of
good good things in terms of kind of
getting people to know what to expect of
a hitman game and what what in what is
the game about and about kind of mastery
of the locations and getting to know all
the ins and outs at the different places
you go to but this time around we're
kind of bundling it up all at once so
you can play for the main story at your
own pace and then at the same time for
the live challenge we did a lot of good
stuff in in the previous game with the
escalations contracts these different
challenges and also the elusive targets
if you know those the these time limited
missions where you really only have one
shot and then your I didn't make it or
yeah I got it
but but this time around by having all
the locations available at launch it
gives us a lot more pieces to play
around with in the in the live tail end
so you don't have to go to the same map
until the next thing came out so this
time around more varied life follow-up
content has it made you reevaluate the
live schedule at all because you kind of
like people the way that content was
doled out last time people spent so much
time in the individual levels and you
kind of had to balances to when
to introduce the live content so how is
it gonna change well I think it's gonna
be more of the same so to speak but
without the big big locations are gonna
be expansions later down the line but
but we had a lot of the way we've
constructed the game right allows us to
kind of add characters right oh so we
don't have to redo the entire thing and
that's what we do for these elusive
targets and also for the escalations we
change things around so you know some of
it which make it like it empowers you
because you have intimate knowledge of
the location but all of a sudden people
have changed that you have to be very
kind of aware and and then still kind of
keep calm and be kind of observant of
what's going on so as you were saying
the locations in the Hitman games are
huge they're pretty like paramount
mastering it as agent 47 is a huge deal
can you tell us about some of the
locations that we'll be seeing in hitman
two well currently we're showing off
Miami here as you see and that I think
that you know 47 is of course the main
star of the show but then the locations
they they played the you know the epic
of lead role as well because every
location gives you something new
something the new stories new characters
all that stuff and and and as you know
we we go to great lengths to do this
right so in Miami the centerpiece is a
race car but then we we kind of you know
have to add all the things around the
race car as well so the track the pits
the paddocks the VIP lounge just to make
this really a living breathing world
with lots of details for you to be
creative in when you go down it and then
we've hinted at a second location that's
kind of dark and dangerous rainforests
where we're saying and which kind of
sent the forum on a hunt for all the
rain forests on the planets okay so
there's a map you can go check out but
it's nice to see how eager they they're
they're kind of odd to figure out what's
going on yeah and that is the most
appealing thing I think are one of the
really appealing things about hitman
games is like and I think that's why ice
people get so passionate is it's about
the locations but it's also about kind
of all the emergent things that can
happen from that and obviously the first
season got such a huge following with
streamers like and it was just because
you can see how the game itself will
just like unfold and
like beats random it's like really crazy
situations will happen but how have you
been what were some things from season 1
that you wanted to change when you're
going into the second game while also
maintaining what makes those hitman
games
I know you're I think you know
internally for the team the the previous
game was like a learning lesson and far
from all the team members have had been
on you know the old ones blood money and
stuff right is so we kind of had to to
reinvent the the sandbox in in in the
first game and that means that now we're
kind of cashing in on all that knowledge
about okay so what makes a great hitman
level how can we make the locations pop
even more and then in Miami we kind of
we dialed it up a notch with the with
bigger crowds than we've ever had right
and then of course it's it had a solid
foundation for us to kind of okay so
what what are we gonna add next and one
of the things we've added now is we've
we've added more depth to the crowd
gameplay so this time around if you get
into trouble you can you can actually
dip into the crowd and the gods will try
to kind of search for you and so it
becomes this cat-and-mouse game and then
another thing we've added is the is this
this briefcase the suitcase where he can
store his sniper rifle because
trafficking around such a big item it
kind of causes a bit of attention so
this is a way for you to kind of you
know get rid of that attention but you
can also use it for other items so it
said it's yet another tool for agent 47
to kind of go about his business
and speaking of agent 47 this game is
gonna delve deeper into his story and
it's not just about you know the
assassinations it's about him as a
character absolutely and the previous
game we we wait to great lengths try to
create a story where where we have some
characters that are still alive
and then we can then use in the in
hitmen too so so and these stories will
come closer together and this time comes
a big becomes a bit more personal on 47s
behalf so it's gonna be interesting to
see how because it is a continuation of
what happened in the in the previous
game but now things are kind of
narrowing in a bit so it's good it's
gonna be very interesting to see how
people kind of get the story and then
also i'm i'm so curious how how you like
design these games as far as like do you
start
with the environment you start with like
you know what the objectives are gonna
be the characters that you could be
potentially assassinating or being
disguised as like can you walk us
through the process of where do we want
to set this mission how do we want it to
play out I'm fascinating to me
absolutely I think it's a it's actually
a very long process that starts with
some ideas right okay so we have the
main story that would like to have
something to happen and then we kind of
go on a hunt for what location could
that take place in and then in this case
okay let's go for the race it fits with
the characters they're part of the the
background world the Kronstadt
industries company and they are doing
some some dirty deeds and then from that
we kind of deduct it okay so the race
what could possibly go wrong at a race
that's then did we ask you know what
could happen what could possibly go
wrong in the kitchen and what could
possibly go wrong that's like a lot of
things come from that and then at the
same time we want the characters to tell
a lot of stories so when you kind of
explore the level and and discover them
you get to know them a lot better you
get their angles on why they're doing
the things and and and a lot of kind of
things to learn about the characters and
then at the same time we want a lot of
the characters to kind of hint at what
you can do with them I just saw for the
seminary a passive flamingo that's one
of these stories that can unfold in the
mission and right now another so that's
one thing and then we just solve for
this Evan woke up some stairs here
weather just an example right we have
some disco balls hanging here at the
staircase and that's one of these things
where okay so we built a location and
then we look at it oh my god these huge
disco balls they look like they could do
something they hit someone right so it
becomes I can we turn them into an
accident and yes in this yes we can so a
lot of it is kind of this iterative
process where we have some core ideas we
put them in and then early on it's you
know the graphics are not there it's
just a shape and then we've kind of
iterate on it and we play it again and
again and again and and and kind of
fine-tune all of these moments so we
have these great experiences where where
players have lots of choice lots of
freedom and they can kind of do as they
want with the game right obviously you
got a very enthusiastic fan base who are
always giving you feedback on things
how do you go about changing things up
in the game to kind of give fans what
they want but also keeping it you know
what you consider to be good game design
that'll actually I think that's a very
good question and in terms of hitman
right it's also very chaotic because
literally we have little idea about what
people are actually doing in the game we
provide them with the canvas where they
can go in and and kind of express
themselves and how they wanted to deal
with the game but we look a lot at the
forum's we have you know user research
going on and during development while we
kind of figure out okay so how is this
work of course there are some ideas was
like wait this is not a good idea if
people don't like it they don't get it
so it's okay let's let's change that up
to something else so again that feeds
into this very big iterative process as
well and but but it's always this fine
balance of okay the the the fans would
really love to do something like this I
know you know we if we look at how the
forums they have you know I would like
to do a mission that said they in the
theater I would like to do a mission
that's this I so there's plenty of ideas
and feedback coming our way and then we
kind of look we've course we look at it
and then and I think I would be lying if
I said okay we're not influenced by this
we totally are but then at the same time
we also have our own creative ideas of
okay we would like to do this feature
next on that deep feature next what are
some of the biggest lessons you learned
from the first game that you're carrying
over whether it's for the level design
for the missions or for just like how
the game plays out I think one of the
one of one of the key factors I'm
looking at when I'm playing the game is
is it's very much this how does it flow
and I think that that's that's a you
know don't have to fast stretches when
nothing happens and there's nothing to
see nothing to interact with right and I
think that that's one of the places
where I think we're refining it a lot
this time around we're we're season one
you know was the first four for us in
that regard so so a lot about the flow I
was saying you're saying she's a co-op
mode as a pre-order bonus you tell us a
little bit more about that absolutely
the game is out November 13 and if your
peer or you get access to a new game
mode called snipe
assassin where agent 47 is kind of
perched on a hillside overlooking this
wedding and there's some targets and a
lot of bodyguards that you need to deal
with and then for the first time and in
the Hitman franchise we're actually
doing a multiplayer component so you can
play it cooperatively with a friend so
yeah you better have picked the right
friend because you know one failed shot
and then you yeah then you're not
friends anymore right I imagine having
to balance everything for a second human
player must have been difficult to say
the least
yes and no um because of the way the
game is constructed right all of these
characters we see in meet are their own
they run on their own impressions and
then they're kind of coordinating
themselves and that that kind of meant
that that bet that the AI was kind of
ready for for for handling two people
sniping at the same time because that's
how they work but but in terms of a
differences I think that the the level
design is a bit different it still has
the same inner workings as a hitman
levels so they're stories that unfold
you can make this wedding go in
different directions based on if the
cake is there or not that's up to you if
you shoot the cake so you can make
someone has have a really really bad
wedding and and and you can also make
someone have a good wedding so so it's
it's very much the same DNA underneath
the hood about the lots of things to
explore lots of things to discover we've
hidden a lot of small things for you to
find in in the mission that you can you
can kind of interact with as well always
reasoning behind introducing it now and
is this something that the fans been
calling out for or is it something you
just kind of wanted to experiment with
it's one was one of these things where
we want to say okay let let us try to do
something new and then different and and
to be honest we have in the previous
past done a sniper mission before and
it's it's very strong fantasy so I think
it fits it fits the the franchise really
really well to have this mode in it
where it's it's it's so condensed into
one thing and I I really really think it
works out really well and people get so
hooked on this thing it's it's it's
amazing it's like people at the studio
kind of have had competitions and okay
how
who's the best sniper assassin and
that's been a lot of kind of inner
fighting going on there it's been a it's
been a blast to go back kind of what
you're talking about with the game flow
in your words what is it that makes the
hitman game so appealing I mean there's
people who play it can understand and
can explain why they're so so fun to
play and so fun like see things I kind
of interact and interweave throughout
the gameplay but in your words what
what's the elevator pitch for hitman
games the elevator pitch would be a
freedom of approach in a sandbox
assassination game that would be kind of
the top top top level pitch and for me
it's very much this you make your own
little plan of attack and then you roll
with it and then things get a bit out of
control and and it's like it's like a
juggling a hot potato so you just took
over the oven without burning your hands
once you get into that phase of the game
I really think it excels and there
another thing for me that I'm really
kind of proud of in the game that's the
NPC's reactions to all the things you're
doing the conversations that they're
having while investigating things and
then that kind of that and that that's a
that's a direct kind of reaction to what
you just did and that that feels like
okay you made you made a difference in
this you made a bump in a dent in the
world and now it's actually trying to
react and trying to kind of catch up and
cope with what you just did and that's
to me one of these things where I think
our game is really responding to you as
a player it's not just triggering
another cutscene with this happens and
that happens so it's very much your own
a narrative you create in this this
mission so I think that for me that's
that's why I like to play the game still
after so many years right it's like yes
I can I still get caught up in this
thing right because oh I'm just gonna
try this and I'm gonna try that why do
you think so many more games nowadays go
toward that like people finding their
own narratives rather than developers
kind of like shoving in on them sorry I
can't I'm just curious why like what
makes what makes it so powerful when a
player can find their own narrative as
opposed to the developer kind of saying
like here's a story and I need to tell
you I think it's it's something about
that the it becomes your own read you
take out you know every time - hitman
fans meet
it's always a blast because one that
they have so different stories to tell
about this game even though they were in
the same place they have completely
different stories to tell how about they
complete the mission what clever things
they did and what they discovered and
have you seen that thing over there and
I think that that's that that's really
rewarding there's so many things to
discover and make your own in the
experience which is which is a very
powerful thing
great well Jacob when can people
watching expect to play hitman two
when they can play it yeah yeah that's a
November 13 and it's a sorry November 13
and if you feel that you get access to
this neither assessing their game mode
and where you can play co-op for the
fruit with a friend for the first time
in the franchise awesome well Jacob
thank you so much for joining us on
stage and have a great rest of the show
thank you and people watching from home
don't go anywhere we're about to talk
about Just Cause 4 we will be right back
you